this is the grounded podcast episode 5
with echo Charles Greg McIntyre great
otherwise known as Greg train yeah Greg
train yep
so Greg train is a long time training
partner of all of us how do you guys
even know each other
did you guys just know each other from
jujitsu yeah but it seemed like there
was some other connection yeah like Tim
right like Tim was like hanging out cuz
I know you for like years and years
before we but we're like hanging out and
stuff yeah you know each other prejudge
it - no okay we met at the Chula Vista
place yeah oh five at what 2005 you left
all the Vista when Dean was teaching in
like out of a kick boxing Academy for a
liquor 91 for the one the half full half
of it yeah that's because there was a
curtain and whatnot but you Greg trained
that was not your first grappling
experience no I've started with Fabio
Santos but that wasn't even your first
grappling experience no wrestling before
this wrassle yeah I started wrestling in
junior high how did you get interested I
hated bike racing bike race yeah well
like BMX bikes race right so my mom
would take us both bike racing and my
brother was into it and so I had to be
in who's older you or your brother my
older brother okay so you take me by
great and I just kind of had to go along
and then I finally found wrestling he
try he was wrestling in high school and
then I wanted a wrestle - so I did the
junior high wrestling and I did really
well so when when you do really well you
don't like it so I say that's kind of
the key with kids you want to like make
them do well with stuff you want to look
not saying you got to let him win but
you want to let him win a little bit
yeah you know what the working dog you
know I'm saying when I say working dog
like an attack oh yeah you know for a
civilian they called attack dog in the
military we call it a working dog the
working dog doesn't lose any scraps yeah
like in training they training it always
wins and they hit it with like a fake
stick that kind of makes a lot of noise
but it doesn't really do anything yeah
that dog thinks it can just when it's
out
in the field it thinks it could kill any
man yes the things every man is a big
boy see that thing is just gonna rip
your face on the mixin but the reality
is like you can get offensive with a dog
and you know you can beat up a dog
because the dog is just a dog
yep right but no I mean they definitely
work so what like where's the balance
there they with kids for example you do
you want them to get beat up like 10% a
time 27 I think you got a you got to
kind of follow it you got to ride the
wave properly right yeah if they're just
starting to dominate then which I think
that the goal is that you wanna you
wanna when they start to dominate and
they're just feeling great then you just
give a little a little pushback bounced
a little nudge back down and they say oh
I need to I need to work a little bit
harder yeah you know I did not do a good
job that with that with my kids with
jiu-jitsu with jiu-jitsu it was your oh
I'm I know what I'm gonna do for my kids
because I'm such a great dad I'm gonna
make everything so hard that they're
gonna be tougher yeah but really it was
like Oh dad you're gonna put us in a
conference I'd put him up a weight class
or two weight classes put him up with
the older kids higher belts and they'd
go to a digit tournament and there's a
big difference between a seven year old
and a ten year old right like there's a
big difference a big difference so I'd
put my seven-year-old kid against a ten
year old kid and he would it's not like
he wasn't training hard but then a
ten-year-old kids tenure that's a huge
difference
yeah and so he'd be all sad that he lost
and of course I'm thinking don't worry
it'll make you tougher yeah hey don't
worry kid you'll be tougher and the kids
that was not fun no not a lot that's why
I tell people now the main goal as a
parent with jiu-jitsu or with anything
is make it fun and into your point Greg
how do you make something fun me win
winning is fun yeah so you you were in
junior high you started winning and
there's a little bit of natural talent
you probably wrestled around with your
brother you had a little edge over the
other kids so all of a sudden you're
winning that makes you want to train
more when you want to train more you win
more when you win more you want to train
more it's a good cycle to get the kids
into yeah yeah that's interesting you
call it the wave because if you do it
too much you don't catch the wave you do
too little you don't catch the wave you
know you got it so kind of mo you got a
much
right like from kid to kid it's gonna be
different I'm a kid too right
yes I'm their temper man yes that's true
some kids have the temperament they want
to go against the hardest kids and then
if you have that then you can you can
push that a little bit further you know
ease towards that side but if you have
the kid that's not like that then you
gotta back off and you just want them to
have fun
some kids it's so weird I mean kids are
just different you know kids are so
different and you gotta you have I mean
you steer them a little bit but they're
they're gonna be a certain way you know
and you're not gonna get your kid to be
exactly how you want him to be I was
with a group of parents well a group of
men and everyone's talking about my kid
this you know it didn't do this and I
said hey who at this table did what your
parents wanted you to do like in life
right the answer is not one person not
one person oh I did exactly what my
parents wanted me to do like who says
that no one says that you know I guess
there's some kid that well my parents
wanted me to go to Stanford and so I
went to Stanford or whatever yeah well
some families they have a tradition you
know we're like the son or the daughter
whatever follows in the footsteps that's
true that's true no I do right now that
I think now I think about I've known
some families that have family
businesses yeah
now not every kid in the family will go
into the family business but there's
usually one or two of them now sometimes
that's a that's a smart decision just
straight financially right there little
business but also they get they raised
with it right they're raised with that
that type of business
yeah I think that's it the expectation
is just kind of there
yeah they don't get told to do one thing
or another I remember in high school
thinking like at when I was graduating
some of my friends were like oh yeah I'm
gonna go to college because it was just
expected I mean nobody went to college
so what did you do straight out of high
school
um I played around in college a little
bit like in college took some classes I
don't know what I was doing then I
started training and competing and then
I was out for a while like a year and a
half for I got a bad disease in my
intestines and that serious surgery and
so
I was out so that do wait what did you
weigh prior to that disease in 75 what
did you weigh like after your lowest
point with that disease I think I lost
like at my worst I lost like 35 pounds
yeah it was pretty bad yeah yeah yeah
you I remember seeing you when you were
sick and I was damn I was shocked bro
yeah as you lost a lot of weight and you
know and just so everyone knows cuz
you're not saying Greg train is 100
percent leave like you know there's no
like fat direct trade Greg train is pure
muscle so yeah when you lost that much
weight that was a lot of weight for you
to lose yeah yeah I know it was a tough
age to lose all that weight because I
was 20 years old I remember coming back
like I was I was I just had caught the
bug you know the Jiu Jitsu bug all
addicted to it and then I wasn't able to
train yet I had like for a while I had
to eat Li ostomy bag and all that but I
remember coming back sitting on the wall
at fabulous and watching you guys and it
was just the worst few months of my life
that's what it felt like anyway Oh cuz
you got a watch you can't anticipate cut
oh yeah the other things weird when you
get injured you feel like hor disease I
assume is the same but you get injured
you feel like it's never gonna get
better
yeah yeah it's actually the worst thing
in the whole entire world
hey you you had to bicep surgeries to
echo yeah so was your second one
mentally worse or was the first one
mentally well first one the first one
was worse everything mentally and
physically the second one you knew what
you had yeah he knew what to deal with
yeah hey I got this yeah and like I knew
what I had to do for rehab and I don't
know if the surgical procedure was more
updated to and I had like that's some
supplementation to enjoy warfare not
like nothing crazy nothing like that but
ya know it was the path to recovery was
way more clear for sure for the second
one yeah did what was the deal with that
disease was there was there a pathway to
where they said you'd be like okay
you'll be recovered from this eventually
before the surgery yeah mmm I think they
just kind of wait and see how severe it
is and then it was a it was a bad case
so like some people just live with it
it's like a mild case or surge of
colitis what we're talking about me and
then they could take these
anti-inflammatory medications and stuff
but for me it was like it was really bad
losing all that weight and they're like
you know I'm sure you need to get rid of
that thing so they took the entire colon
out which fixed a lot of the problem I
solve some issues obviously you need
like it's convenient to have a colon but
I'm you know it's a lot it's a lot
better than having a disease you know
yeah but yeah there's there's people out
there to have a mild case of it and
they're fine you know so when did you
when was that okay so you started
training right jiu-jitsu and then how
long from the time you started trying to
jujitsu did you find out that you had so
I think I was pretty deep in my blue
bill with Fabio so a couple years came
yeah were you fighting it because you
were in king of the cage I remember it
cuz I remember I had I bought you know
the old king of the KH videos yeah sure
enough I watch that and this was like
when I was like fired up to be and cuz
I've started jiu-jitsu because I was
gonna fight MMA so I was like okay you
know watch all the king of the cages and
Dean was on there so I was like fired up
that was get to train with Dean and then
I see him on there I'm like oh my gosh
my team is so awesome or whatever um you
seemed bigger though okay so there she
is with that before that was in your
head yeah it was it was going on for a
couple years like while I was competing
and then I was young like what 19 at the
time and super not even like I I was
like I'll just deal with this it's okay
yeah you know but that was before the
surgery
the I was before the surgery so it took
a while to get like as bad as it got to
where I needed surgery anybody I was
like competing with the disease oh and
yeah I was you were ready for
competition though because wrestling
makes you so ready for competition yeah
so ready for jiu-jitsu competition yeah
was that that that stage where you
remember when you write around Bluebell
you just want to compete it
yeah yeah that was a good time and then
how long were you out with it I mean I
serve on alright so I was out for a
while and and then I had the surgery and
then there was like a second part
surgery where they they like made what's
called a J pouch out of my small
intestine like make kind of like take
place of the colon a little bit and then
when that healed up there to go back in
like connect it to my intestines and
stuff like that but also just do it
straight plumbing inside yeah yeah and
the way that they talk about it they
they talk like they're plumbers yeah
sound like super tech it's weird some of
the doctors that do like surgery on your
bones and stuff they're doing
construction in there there and there
with hammers and chisels and stuff you
know yes they're getting busy now you
had the plumbers in there yeah putting
together piping yeah I'm actually in
there in the or seen this stuff weekly
cuz I'm an x-ray tech oh and and I see
that the orthopod we got dr. Luke here
training with us yeah those guys
especially the ortho guys they're just
and the spine guys too but yeah they're
construction workers they're in there
hammering away it's not like careful
surgical I have and it's that raizy so
the one was your when was your first
fight after you saw after you heal after
you had the surgery how long did it take
before you were kind of alright I'm back
in the game now
jeez it was at least a year and a half
and then and then I kept trained you do
so I was even sure if I was gonna get
back to fighting because I fought I
fought like with like two weeks of two
dudes experience first I guess a
wrestler do I do good I have a I think I
won yeah the video is hilarious like
double leg arm bar on the pound what you
do yeah so out a few fights there's
everything and they're just like it was
like old-school UFC there's like all
these different disciplines in there it
wasn't even MMA yet yeah I'm talking
1999 yeah and then yeah and and so we're
fighting it was in a nightclub in San
Pedro again so yeah it was not even
illegal is completely unsafe yeah I was
told that they were pretending it was
like a WWE type of thing and the results
were like predetermined but really it
wasn't but that's how they got away with
like making a fight and then when I was
19 I think whatever yeah whatever fight
but yeah so was your first fight how
would you win so i armoir this guy that
was like from what position from the
bottom the guy I was on the bottom
I double like the guy I gotta show you
the video Larry yeah so tell me the
fight yeah so I were fired double leg
the guy run him across the cage and I
get on top he's super athletic strong
yet he's stronger than I and then he
ends up turning and getting on top and
then I turn for this like super sloppy
armbar and then I and I got it and I was
going not to like because this guy was a
champion if you like break your cousin's
nose or so yeah he fought my cousin
broke his nose before that so I won that
and I won another fight
it's kind of super sketchy like I would
not want to have a two week of jiu-jitsu
trained Greg train grabbing my arm and
trying to it in fight right how hard
were you go when you got a hold of that
thing but you were try to rip that thing
off of his body as long as I can so that
was the first fight it was a layers I
was wearing like like biking shorts and
wrestling shoes and then I won another
fight and then I actually the one that I
lost there and those it was like this is
dancing waters like nightclub I then I
fought again against Javier Vasquez oh
yeah there yeah and he was a I was still
a white belt he's a purple at the time
but I my wrestling working for me a
little bit he actually is a good
wrestler also yeah yeah yes but uh I
took him down and then we scrambled a
little bit and then he got me this
armoire and like I like pick him up just
like I'm like a deadlift and he was like
like parallel to the mat hold them
straight out and uh and then I like slam
him down and I end up in a triangle and
he he finished me there yeah but yeah
dude
fighting happy Vasquez yeah back it has
a white felt really a purple bow and
back then a purple belt was my butt yeah
that's like no black belt today you know
they're so rare yeah yeah no purple
Lobos series yeah hobby Vasquez was
running stuff on the circuit you know he
was you know cuz back that's in the time
when you know me and Dean were competing
all time you were competing but we'd go
up to those big grabbing us and having
Vasquez would always be crushed and keep
those things yeah see he was like one of
the first guys that was at that like a
high level Judas who also had high-level
wrestling yeah and he was using it such
in the right way and he was great he was
tearing - yeah full of life
there's a lot of those guys now oh yeah
now it's the crazy thing is in San Diego
in San Diego the girl wrestlers almost
all the good girl wrestlers are Jiu
Jitsu originally they're all Jiu Jitsu
girls well a lot of them because you get
to so popular in San Diego that they
just start they start doing jiu-jitsu in
there or whatever they're ten years old
I started doing jiu-jitsu and then they
do in jiu-jitsu and then they show up in
high school and someone says hey you
should wrestle and boom there you go and
they have all that background and
there's not a lot of girls that just
grew up wrestling in San Diego so yeah
nowadays it's so common that people do
both yeah that's crazy to start and you
and then go to wrestling that's unheard
of when I started yeah that's kind of
common now so then how many fights did
you eat did you have before you had your
surgery just fight random night clubs
dumb you know you you know it was it's
what you're picturing right now yeah
like people like oh yeah you know up
against this the the cage like this is
the two years that I was this is when I
left Fabio's I was in Virginia Beach
right now so that's why that's why I'm
not that's why I don't remember that's
why I wasn't at these fights when I was
in Virginia Beach from 98 to 2000 and so
I wasn't here so you because I remember
you and then I left and then you were
fighting in nightclubs yeah Roadhouse
maybe we should change ages Dave from
Gregg chain to Roadhouse
I remember that
I remember when you came back that first
time like you must have left right when
I started yeah we're real close yeah and
then I and then you came back and I knew
of you but then you showed up nothing oh
that's the guy and then yeah the weird
thing was I I was I got my blue belt
pretty fast from Fabio and then like
probably when I was starting to be like
right around ready for my purple belt I
left yeah so I show up at my gym with
Gustavo Machado out in Virginia Beach
and I trained there and I trained with
Frank Frank Gucci some too so but I was
trained in there but like they weren't
gonna give me my purple ball cuz I again
back then you weren't just given away a
purple ball to some dude you know you
need to know that dude you need to have
like a blood trust relationship so
Gustavo probably needed me to be there
for another pretty good chunk I talked
about I was only there for two years so
I train train train train and then I
came back to California so when I came
back to California Bobby was looking at
me like I just skipped practice for to
know you've been skipping practice for
two years you think you're gonna get
promoted no you're back at the bottom of
the blue belt wrong so I hadn't stripes
I was getting stripes did you get
stripes on your blue belts no I got
stripes
I had four stripe I got a one stripe
when I came back after being a flip
after being a blue belt for like for
like three years I come back and Fabio
gives me a stripe after like six months
it gives me a stripe on that thing I was
like you didn't like that did he get
been six months later gives me I was
ended up being a blue belt forever yeah
I need a guy funny and gave me my purple
ball purple belt to me was kind of a big
deal that was the biggest deal to me bro
I feel like he would make people
struggle for the belt more if they were
like physical and aggressive you know
what are you trying to say cuz I came in
as a wrestler yeah
um and so he would like SiC Dean on me
at first or Higgs yeah and just like
sort of teach me a lesson and yeah and I
loved those lessons yeah for sure but
yeah he would if you're especially if
you had some wrestling experience or and
you were more physical yeah I think he'd
he'd make us wait longer yeah cuz it's
like you can't just roll in here with
your wrestling and think you're gonna
get our best kind of thing you know yeah
yeah I could see it need to get you need
to get tapped out a bunch by Dean Lister
yeah it's like you got a it's almost
like Fabio would be like and obviously I
can't speak for him so I don't know but
it seems like anyway he'd be like like
yeah a good good wrestling very
effective but I'm here to teach you
jujitsu so I'm gonna teach you something
did you - Dean teach him some jujitsu
and then when you learn that ok I'll
give you your belt no matter how
effective your reckoning this time Dean
only weighed like a hundred and seven
well by this time he might have been
heavier by this time he might have been
up to 185 but when he I when I started
training he was 174 and the weird thing
is I can't say he felt as heavy on top
because he didn't but he still felt
heavy but his still is strong like you
know you grab you then you just say man
this is I can't move he still felt like
that even when he was 174 even he was
and he was only 19 years old he was a
little kid he was freaking strong yeah
any other technique you know he had that
random technique okay so how many fights
did you have before you went and got
surgery jeez I'm trying to remember
there were a couple of those fights the
dancing waters clear that weren't
recorded yeah they're just unsafe yeah
and they're not on Sherdog there so I
had those and then one gladiator
challenge and then I like maybe four for
the DeLaet this the tulip before my
surgery where I should had no business
fighting did you did you win him or did
you lose now I lost I lost that because
you were trying to cut weight your body
wasn't getting nutrition and it was just
a total at the time like the disease
it's an autoimmune disease so sometimes
it will flare up and get real
and sometimes it wasn't so bad and so I
would so I plan to go to like Denver for
this fight for example you know wait and
I was feeling okay and then because of
the flight or I don't know what it was
like like stress like sort of flares it
up or something and then suddenly I'm
like pulling all this blood and like I'm
flaring up from atoms cramping up and
everything so you should not have been
fighting now I shouldn't have been
fighting out it like any my cousin was
with me nice L mean there's probably a
bad idea but he was like tiptoeing
around it you know yeah all the way out
yeah so I but I remember in this on
video they I was mounted and and like is
almost like someone reached down and
took the batteries out of me and I'm
mounting the guys looking at me there's
knowing that I'm dead like mounted he
starts punching me from the bottom was
mounted
yeah it was bad and then I had to go to
the hospital afterwards I was like I
wasn't really is that what made you
finally decide like okay I didn't do do
something about this yeah I mean I
didn't decide after that the flare up
got so bad right after that fight to
where I started losing weight like every
day like a little bit okay so so yeah
they just they admitted me into the
hospital and and started everything but
on oh yeah so I was able to like a few
years later come back and try it again
anyway you came back you came back you
had some good scraps yeah yeah well
would what did you record under bed geez
what is it it's just 10 and for how many
fights did you have in the WEC WC 2
fights 2 fights yeah win or lose I lost
yeah thanks Ari who'd you lose sir I
lost to the first one was guiding
Budnick and I was winning the fight for
what like 13 of the 15 minutes
got triangle I'm punching the guy on top
and I'm gassing they're inexperienced
and got triangle but uh yeah so there
are a few fights leading up to that one
that I won and then there was the the
one that was featured on the tapout
episode and in that one that's right at
that one that one sort of like pushed me
into the WC which was awesome yeah but
uh for those either don't know that WC
was kind of the lightweight UFC not not
just not meaning like lightweight UFC
but the guys that were lighter weight
yeah they would fight WC back in the day
and then and then W and then UFC bottom
and then they started the small weight
classes yeah I see I think I'm yeah I
thought I knew what I was doing to
because you know you're winning and but
then in retrospect like I had no idea
what I was doing that's bad that the
trainings in volleyball since into their
the way they're doing it now and uh I
mean I was barely I was I wasn't
training the right way if you got a spar
more all that stuff yeah like I thought
my boxing was decent and then looking
back it was terrible that kind of thing
that was cool when to tap out guys came
yeah I'll tell you the sky scrape
actually I put those guys both on this
seat to lower mm-hmm and said you know
this is what you should be able to do
and I was kind of talking smack to him
you know and both those guys grinded it
out like their life depended on it and
both of them got I don't know what they
got but they both got a sub 1:30 500
which is respectable you know for for
Cummins like scrape its me like you kind
of thought mask would do it because he
was kind of you know like in shape
walking around with a shirt off like
echo does even talking about do that he
was kind of like that but then also the
thing is scrapes 19 feet tall which does
give you an advantage on the c2 rower
hmm and punk ass I mean it was punk ass
down here yeah yeah I don't think he got
on it he said I'm not doing that but
yeah then you that got you so that got
you into the W that's what did it yeah
yeah I think the exposures from that for
sure and then to the WEC then you you
lost your fights in the WEC yeah it
seemed like it was hard for you to to
like have your energy up after you got
that surgery is that is that a correct
assessment or you think you just trained
wrong probably combination but I mean
there's a lot I could have trained
better I could train harder you know but
um but yeah it does suck some energy out
of you because you're your body's always
sort of even if you have like like a
tooth infection like a small one and
your immune systems fighting it you have
less energy for everything else you know
so so I think I was like constantly sort
of dealing with the inflammation process
of that and then so it would it was
harder to go as hard as I wanted to go
for sure but um but there are other
factors I wouldn't blame it on the
disease because the the entire colon was
gone so the the problem was removed
mostly but there was just a little bit
of it left and so then what made you
decide like all right you know what I
don't think I'm gonna fight anymore dang
good question
are you still thinking about getting
back in the cage and I'm washed up
no my last fight at one we had that
fight were you around it was at Camp
Pendleton you know I went to I wasn't I
didn't go to it yeah it was been
traveling all right it was another xwc
guy
Kenneth Alexander I fought at Camp
Pendleton and I felt good started
finally feeling like I knew how to fight
you know for the first time
and then I did well armbar that guy and
from what position from the bottom if
you beat on the bottom yeah that's crazy
to me I got on top but I think because I
was I was striking I was throwing a lot
of punches and kicks and he grabbed my
foot he's a wrestler oh okay grab my
foot put me on the bottom then I ended
up getting me in an arm lock but um and
then I think I planned on fighting after
that but then I had a menace getting me
on my my knee and then another one then
all this time started going by and then
like I got it just start doing some
adult stuff
go to school or education yeah cuz at
one point you asked me you were like hey
man here's what's going on in my life
right now I could uh I could just train
yeah I could train that's it and I'll
make a little bit of money from teaching
classes and just get by or I can go to
this x-ray tech school and become an
x-ray technician and I remember telling
you go become it's an x-ray technician
not because I didn't think you could you
know go for it in the fight world but
because even to go for it in the fight
world you can't this isn't just because
you become a fighter doesn't mean your
foot it doesn't mean you're working out
for 16 hours a day it's not yeah 16
hours day of working out and now eight
hours of sleep no that's not what
happens and I said listen go there
you're gonna get a job in a hospital
which means you'll have good medical
coverage you you can work eight hours a
day cuz it's a pretty standard kind of
job that has standard hours so you work
your eight hours a day and I said that
leaves you eight hours to Train yeah
that's what you said you basically you
didn't say be an extra take you said do
both yeah yeah I said you both yeah
because okay and that's I think that's
the smartest move because you think
about it when you're an x-ray tech
you've got a regular income you can buy
things like food you know you can buy
things like wraps for your knees because
you know I've had fighters over the
years where they've been like I really
wish I could get a knee pad you know
keep in mind that's most fighters that
is most fighters for sure most fighters
says hey do you you know I saw you
throwing a knee pad in the garbage cuz
it had a bunch of holes in it can can I
have that mmm yeah you can man in fact
I'll get you a new knee can have one
this one right here cause eight dollars
but people yeah man it's a tough row is
it tough row there's no money in
fighting not for a long time I mean the
amount of people in the UFC that have
actually set themselves up is teeny tiny
number of people most people and it's
better now of course but back then
well that's why you have to start when
you're young because there's there's no
there's no payoff
there's the payoff is life experience
and the excitement of it and even if you
do well a lot of guys that do well for a
while unless there are the top guys on
the Billboard they're still not making
that much you know I know same thing
with boxing it's the same it's just you
got to be the star it's got to be the
star to make money from it how much are
other things like that like if you're
gonna be an actor do you think most
actors are just yes I think acting is
another one yeah oh yeah I think it is
because they talk about how most people
in LA or waitresses relators it and they
say what do you do oh I'm an actor
but I just have to wait tables right now
yes that is that's normal oh yeah I mean
you figure even if even like full-on SAG
actor it's like who are in movie I mean
you know you have that upper echelon and
be less kind of situation and once you
kind of go beyond there in the c-list
scenario
oceans upon oceans upon oceans of actors
if just chilling waiting tables or
whatever musicians same thing now that I
think about it right there's not too
many musicians that are just out there
raking in the money yeah yeah in fact
most of them are yeah isn't Jordan
Peterson talk about this in a way he
talks about the purrito prince of wars
yeah you get it makes sense all these
they're off prison around the waiting
tables or bartending or something and
then once they get an opportunity that
opportunity leaves you another one which
leads to five more opportunities then
and then they're pushing opportunities
away so you either have nothing then
there's some some point there's like a
tipping point or they have tons of
opportunities yeah well what I heard him
say the other day that I thought was
funny he's like if you're creative then
you're probably poor because the
creative personalities are usually not
people that are conscientious which
means the kind of people that are like
okay well I've got it kind of prepare
for me for the next you know six months
financially the creative people are
saying I'll just make it happen
yeah
and so and the creative people are
generally pours what we say in which
this actually fits into this whole idea
you know make sense of what it is so
when did you get your black belt let's
see oh 9 mm no it was it was right after
your W kiss so you did not the WC fight
sorry the the fight you did on the top
out show that was the one you won by
decision but you had that guy in the
armbar for like a long last time and he
was like so that was it right had a
black belt for that fight you did yeah
like right before that fight oh yeah so
I hear was that it was not oh nice it
wasn't no earlier yeah it seems like it
was earlier I feel like I should know
that yes cuz we were all victory opened
it was called throat out
yeah in like oh seven yeah black belt I
remember the phrase day you really
opened the doors for us in O seven but
the actual official opening for grand
opening was oh wait was January 2nd 2008
yes so you must like either got it in oh
six or seven you were here with like we
no no no no we had this gym when he got
it almost lost us no 100% sure cuz the
day he rolls in with his black belt he
was teaching nogi and I wonder was there
a box in club okay yeah no maybe you got
your black belt with a boxing club I did
yeah it wasn't why I there we go
so then yeah I got in like oh seven you
must have got it no seven ding I only
got mine in oh five so that's cool cuz I
got my white belt in oh five there you
go joined in oh five that day when you
rolled in your teaching nogi and you put
on your gear and you're like oh I'm cold
let me put on my gear put on your black
belt and I see what you did this yeah oh
thank you and I was like I dig it cuz I
probably would have done that thing too
cuz I had never seen anyone do that
before anything I knew you just know not
maybe not me specifically but I'm just
saying just kind of let everybody to
hate guys not a brown belt anymore I
don't remember that story but I'm sure
it's true when I first got I was excited
I go slice em all
yeah does my assumption though you know
I think I actually got my black belt no
six no yours was all five two because
and it's weird more like I'm the super
fan knows whenever I know that you got
yours at that time because I remember it
specifically I know you got yours in oh
five because I got my blue belt in oh
six and you were a black belt when I
started okay
yes now that I remember so I was I think
I just got to SEAL team 3 task unit
bruiser when I got my black belt like a
few month that's what it was so that was
a five a few months before I showed up I
had that black belt I'm pretty sure but
I remember getting my purple belt I was
very excited to get my purple belt and
you think that that was the most
exciting belt to get that was by the
time I got my black belt it was kind of
predetermined that I was you know yeah
like whatever I kind of felt like me
well yeah of course I'm gonna get my
black belt yeah when you're when I was a
blue belt I'm thinking well maybe I'm
not
maybe I'm just never getting my purple
belt maybe I'll just be on this this
blue belt permanently yeah I think
that's common I think like there's a sea
of blue belts and maybe less than half
of them and purple belts yeah purple
gloves but once you get the purple you
might as well keep going
you're probably addicted by then anyway
yeah but a lot of blue bells quit okay
yeah that's all it's gonna ask cuz you
don't seem like the type that would be
hung up on like where my private Olli
did not care
yeah so and that's a strength because
that's hard to dartium to mindset wise
or a keen discrete bit I was like that
until like mid purple belt I was like I
didn't know I was gonna get a probably
this just busted it out one day I'm like
oh cool I guess I'm a purple belt now
same thing with blue girl I didn't know
but do you think how you're saying like
blue belts kind of get stuck in blue
belt
do you think it's because they just hit
plateaus at that time or they quit and
if they quit here's my little hypothesis
because when your white belt it's
essentially like you don't have a belt
right you just white belly you can
literally come in the first day you're a
white belt but when you get a blue belt
you got some color so some people they
got they have this the payoff you know
it's like their balloon kind of gets
popped the they they got their payoff
and they sorted they're just sort of
less motivated now you know so they just
sort of fade out you know I got my blue
belt I'm good yeah probably is probably
a lot of reasons it's it's hard to
figure out like why people quit because
they're all different but I think when
you first get a blue belt it's just like
you're you've just started you do so
you're a white bull you're your zero
belt you know you know nothing and then
you learn a few things you learn some
basics and you get a blue belt blue
bells the easiest one to get right yeah
you learn some basics and so you're
still not fully in the game you're not
like fully committed mentally but
there's no bra it's fully committed when
I was a white belt for crying out loud
yeah yeah you're kindly you so that's
you know but for real you said the same
thing like the night that you walked
into the middle you got armlock the
first time you must have been like oh
this is awesome
I'm gonna do yeah same way I coach oh
yes sir it was so there you go so you're
committed but he's talking about the
people who quit who end up quitting I'll
actually say this and actually this is a
proof kind of like a question to your
hypothesis when you don't know anything
you're all amped up that's what's weird
is that people lose that hype yeah some
people lose it I never lost it I still
like I'm amazed when I learned something
new man I went over a drill yesterday
with Dean 28 times and I just couldn't
believe the little details he was
telling me on this thing just a little
just a little coming up on the single
from a weird little half guard position
I had been making a mistake for a long
time and and there you go
and he chilled me nine little details
and then three more little details yeah
and I just went home thinking man I'm so
lost
like I have so much work to do and I
need to get so much better you know well
yeah I think I mean you're in a way like
you you're like an exception you're an
even even girl and I think what happens
is people go oh I'm a blue belt now I
can pretty much handle most people right
yeah how many people do I need to be
able to have I will say this what my
first interest in jiu-jitsu was like
well I definitely want to do this so I
can take you know like get handle myself
in a street fight well after six months
you know
you can handle yourself in a street
fight and then it wasn't about handling
myself in the street friend anymore now
it wasn't being able to handle Dean
Lester and and James Nielson and Higgs
and and correct like all those
old-school guys from our crew of Fabio's
I wanted to be able to hang with those
guys yeah yeah I mean you some people
are like us to where they get obsessed
you know and we're like laying in bed
thinking about it every night do it
walks to your old lady yeah she puts her
hand yeah but I think a lot of people I
mean I think there's any specific like
preventable way to keep people from
quitting some people just don't love it
as much as we do yeah this is what I
think okay picture this you just like a
random person John Doe starts to get too
brand-new like he goes oh my gosh
there's so much stuff to learn and they
the starts to learn he's you know his
wife says oh you gonna train tonight oh
yeah I'm gonna train tonight then you
fat then he fast forward six months and
he kind of knows like some good stuff he
doesn't get us Bluebell yet but he's
he's feeling you know like well I know I
know pretty much the kind of d the
excitement is gone and so then his
wife's like hey are you gonna train
tonight cuz I really want to hang out
and he says well uh you know what uh
we'll hang out I'll come home early like
so then he just maybe goes he does like
two rounds and he bails yeah then you
fast forward a year and a half he's got
his blue belt there's not much mystery
anymore he's the learning curve also
right the learning curve just like
lifting everyone when they start lifting
they get all Jack they get all strong
for the first time there you get that
steep curve and then also they get to
the point where the difference between
you know benching 315 and Ben chin 335
takes a lot of work whereas going from
from you know 135 up to 225 like you can
get there pretty quick yeah so likely
that's what happens too and all of a
sudden the wife says you know hey do you
want to go out tonight he says yeah yeah
let's go out yeah I don't trying to
blame all the wives out there sorry
sorry ladies but you know I know the
reason I say that is because I had a lot
of conversations with my wife about that
over the years I'm really gonna train
tonight the
it was yes I'm gonna trade tonight yeah
that's what's gonna happen but when I
say like you guys are exceptions like
we'll just say a normal person doesn't
have like strong jujitsu aspirations
even if they love doing it or you know
stuff like that they'll go and you know
they'll it'll be common to skip like a
week of training
I'll just go one day this week yeah
that's like comment for a normal person
weird
you only know bruh you're weird and Greg
is weird for you know like wanting to
fight and not weird like a weird person
I'm just saying you guys are different
than a normal person so it just seems
like yeah once you get a blue bell
you're like dang
hey there's also like a ton of people
that are just full-on committed to
that's or let's face it yeah but a and I
dig it but let's say like you go into a
gym pretty much at least 50% of the
purple belts are in the game yeah right
in the game yes sir but it that's a rare
situation where you see more purple
belts than white or blue belts usually
it's all white and blue belts and then
it's sort of sort of tapers off as you
go up well though yeah the purple belts
are the bluebells that didn't quit yeah
and then blue the blue bells are quit
they're never they never be comfortable
so the pro bells are that's what that's
how you know these guys are yes yes
they're serious but but in with purple
balls there's some purple bots that are
training because no they like it it's
fun they know some skills but then
there's purple balls that are just boy
sharpest yeah oh yeah sharp teeth
exactly yeah and there's like there's
kind of two lanes and probably more than
two where yeah that's it you know if you
have jiu-jitsu aspirations of a math
aspiration whatever you oh yeah you're
gonna fly through those belts like your
name boom purple boom that's why it like
yeah guys won't guys don't reach purple
belt and then sort of quit they do but
it's really rare less person and then
brown belt is even more because like
guys don't make it to brown belt and
that and when you think about it that's
why there's the least probably brown
belt in this is the total guess but
there's probably less brown belts than
any other belt because once your black
belt
whether you quit or keep going there's
no other I mean there's the red belt and
all that and I get it but let's face it
that's probably the rarest but um when
you consider of white to black when you
consider white to black once you reach
black belt you're but you're a black Oh
there's nowhere you don't
you don't skill out of black belt yeah
typically you know so there's gonna be a
bunch of black belts but brown belt is
that one that you have to be one of the
elite few that stuck with it and then
sorted and you haven't made it yet and
you just haven't made it yet exactly
right so you can skip school out of that
yeah no I would say the other thing that
you've got supporting your hypothesis is
that yeah you're a black belt forever
basically yes so anyone that gets their
black belt counts in the pool of black
belts yeah whereas brown belts there's a
it's the smallest number of people that
came through all the other ranks and
haven't made it a black belt so you are
you saying that like you're sort of
elite and also rare oh yeah like Drake
chain and I are over it as black belt
it's gonna come run of the mill you know
super common situation and brown belt
anyway is a good hypothesis I thought
yeah it was good
so what keeps you going to the mat Gregg
train I love it I mean I've had a couple
big injuries - you've had a neck injury
that was pretty significant you've had
any surgery yeah you they're all pretty
minor they're all meniscus related knee
surgeries uh-huh but one was a repairs
like six-month recovery and if you're
listening and your doctor says you need
a meniscus repair and you guys are
training jiu-jitsu tell him no I just
need the trim because it won't stay
there like meniscus repairs are for
people that have like regular activity
and they're just cruising around and
then it'll probably work but if you have
a meniscus repair is where they they go
in there and like the torn piece they
like sew it back down and hope it stays
but you they don't understand like if
you're trained jujitsu you you're gonna
pull those stitches right out which is
what happened to me and then I had
another one they just ended up trimming
it out which they should have done the
first time so when you're young enough
they want you to try the repair but
unfortunately for trained jujitsu it's
just gonna tear out anyway so go
straight to the trim let's go straight
to the trim what is that what's the
negatives that what's the downsides of
the trim the trim is like the meniscus
you have the more chance you have to
have like arthritis and stuff later on
when you're
60 yeah so now since I've had three
minutes ketamine's I just like I'm not
gonna run I'm not a runner I just kind
of could mean I hate running but no I
think what you just said applies to like
mid purple level to like you once you
get there it's it's more than just this
thing you do it's like part of your
identity a little bit yeah and you're
not gonna quit it's like that's not an
option yeah you're just gonna cuz you
love it's part of who you are a little
bit here's a here's a I guess this is
the point that I am thinking about the
putting your ego in check because let's
face it when you get back on the mats
after you've been out for six months
you're not you know you're everyone you
know we always talk about how you I
can't tell if I'm getting any better
that's cuz everyone's on the bus yeah it
was on that same bus going the same
direction so you can't tell like man
eklund I've been training and you know
I'm just not getting any better it's
like no because we're both getting
better yeah so what happens is when you
get off that bus you come to school six
months later your timing is off you're
auditioning is off you haven't learned
new moves you haven't progress your game
and you're gonna get beat by people that
you were beating and that hurts I I had
a my knee hurt right and I okay I went
from my elbow being hurt to my knee
being hurt there's been a not the best
year as far as like getting after it
in all the ways that I like to but
here's a here's a case in point of the
example so when my I hurt my elbow I
could not do overhead squats I mean I
could not do him I could not extend my
elbow and and and do it I just could not
do it
so no overhead squats and that was a
solid like five months no overhead
squats okay then right on the tail end
of like oh I think I can extend my hurt
my knee
and so now no no squats any of you any
kind so the other day I'm I'm I said to
myself okay well you know I can do a
squat all the way I have full range of
motion it hurts a little bit and I can
extend my elbow I'm gonna do overhead
squats I was horrible horrible yeah I
mean just weak you know the mobility is
not there just all those things and
and I could see you know what I saw in
front of me I saw the trap
I saw the trap in front of me well I saw
the trap let's wrap the trap is the ego
that says well I'm just not gonna do
them
it's not even ego it's like hey I see
how people end up we know I used to be
able to do this because it'd be real
easy for me to say it well you know
overhead squats aren't really that
important it's like no actually overhead
squats are important and and and so what
I need to do you don't need to do put my
ego and Shack back on the bus and get
back on the bus and start with the PVC
the PVC pipe get in that range of motion
back that's what it takes man yeah
that's what it takes but it's either you
either you see that trap and you
identify it and I see people do this all
the time or you allow that trap to catch
you yeah and when you allow that trap to
catch you you you all you do is you just
rationalize you just rationalize me well
you know I don't what you know that's
not you know I don't need you think of
the million ways that you can
rationalize you know overhead squats or
that Euless that's not really you know
it's like overhead squats are good for
you
you have to keep doing these movements
the movements that are hard to do you
have to do them you have to do them and
you have to keep moving and so the same
thing happens in jiu-jitsu right it's
real easy to go from you know well if
I'm coming back on the mat been injured
for a while you know you're gonna get
beat up you know guys that you have beat
before that are below you in the
hierarchy of jiu-jitsu they're gonna
rise above you and that is enough to
make some people say well you know what
I'm just not gonna train neither no I
trained with that person or I'm not
gonna train at all yeah oh yeah and
that's what I'm saying you know that's
why I like Gordon Gordon to your whole
time like he has a dinged-up neck it's
bad but he comes out and he trains you
know he if nothing else he drills and he
goes and learns new moves and practices
other moves and you know Gordon
was is no joke you know of a jujitsu guy
like if he if he wasn't gonna be laid up
for a while after every time he rolled
his bad neck I mean dude yo Jordan
through I mean uh Gordon throws all
kinds of crazy jiu-jitsu and so that's
to me that's awesome that he says you
know what I can't roll right now and he
I don't know if y'all build roll again I
don't know but he I can't roll it now so
you don't to do well I'm gonna do what I
can
yeah I'm gonna do what I can and that's
that takes a lot of desk your world with
him last week um was it like a live role
or was it like limited yeah yeah yeah
exactly what you said though he does
what it can so he'll be like hey I'm not
gonna roll with everyone you know I'm
gonna grab great someone who I trust
yeah
you know and let them know remind them
hey and my next jammed up let's do a
light roll someone who can do a light
roll yeah which is another whole nother
thing yeah yeah cuz some people they
talk about relaxing but then they don't
echo Charles negative all with you know
I'm not relaxing and even if I say let's
just go light and I don't go light oh
that's on purpose that's a that's a
bigger strategy give them give the
mental game on me yeah kind of yeah but
so I think that's like my lesson for
this like past couple months has been
just identifying that that trap is out
there and it's real easy to fall into
the trap of hey make excuses rationalize
this isn't important or you can put your
ego in check because that's really what
it is oh really you're my ego going into
checks and ho I'm gonna get out the PVC
pipe you know which ways is 0 pounds
yeah and I'm gonna start doing overhead
squats again because I can either that
where you go you know what overhead
squats aren't that really excuse yeah
did you see is like that probably times
two because you have that added element
of like ego versus ego cuz you're going
against a person like you're doing
overhead squats even at a public gym
you'll see just like okay maybe
someone's looking at me maybe not
whatever
alright here at your own gym yeah yeah
it's like brothers that's no factor it's
just you against you and then it's like
okay but you have a jujitsu you have
sure other people watching but whatever
but you have the guy you're rolling with
like you ever get tap
and we were talking about this today if
you get tapped out by a guy who you
always tap out that's an uncomfortable
day right there
no good as far as feeling at that moment
yeah well there's a lot of things that
go into that of course but I'm saying
the primary feeling that you get is not
good men like when someone below you
tops you out even if you're the same
belt but you always get them you know
like they've never tapped you up for and
then they get you right it it's not
comfortable it's not good let's face it
it sucks real bad yeah but as you were
talking about that story today like I
whenever I find someone that's gonna be
good man I train with them all the time
try and get him better and get me better
and try and get them to tap me that's my
goal that's that's very noble and very
mature thank you and I get it
but I'm saying and even you by your
brain I was about to say to you don't
get me wrong and even even when you said
this to Andy today like you're like well
you know now that now that you you know
you tap Jocko so that's kind of like an
or it happens
and so it's like jock was cool with that
even and he's like well no he's not good
like no like of course yeah of course no
to just be straight up never mind
someone that never tapped me before I
don't like tapping I don't like getting
tapped out by anyone at any time right I
understand I think I think everyone in
judges who in jujitsu is like cool I got
tapped out no that doesn't work they're
losing you just lost yes okay so great
train chocolate you're chocol just said
I'd like basically I don't like to tap
ever you know this stuff and then before
that he was like oh you know gives me a
better training partner or whatever
which is they're both true by the way
yeah but their one is like that you're
higher level maturity one is the primal
graduation and I get it but here's the
thing you say okay let's say Andy he
tapped me out the first time that was a
long time ago or whatever now it's like
if he taps you out it's like that's
quote-unquote nothing new we'll call it
will say it in those terms yeah so but
as you say when he taps you out you're
mad you don't like that ever right
so you're saying yeah and even mad
strong words yeah yeah like it's like
you know what I like it whatever
yeah well however you want to put it I'm
just saying that there's nothing yeah so
you're saying if you tap out to Andy now
and you compare that to the feeling that
primal feeling you got when he first
tapped you out or when it was new
you're saying they're the same are you
saying they're the same Billy no no the
first time was worse right for sure
okay so first sure and that's the point
that's exactly what I said today what I
said today was when when you tap someone
out for the first time ever that person
you like crossed into a new boundary
yeah you crossing the unknown yeah
because you you never tapped that person
think about that you think about how
much you roll with someone you could
never tap them that's that's kind of
crazy I don't have to think about that
but yeah I'm saying one day you're gonna
tap me out and you're gonna be like
you're gonna feel like that's gonna feel
good and I'll be like don't damn that
was you know yeah and then there's the
other thing that we talked about today
too is let's face it if you tapped me
out one time you wouldn't immediately be
like okay yeah yeah yeah but the over
time if you started putting the pressure
in then all the sudden you start you
know you could you could definitely
equalize right you could equalize we're
like well we're pretty close you know
that can happen yeah but the thing
that's cool about when you get tapped
out by someone is you know for me this
is my ego is now your ego gets submitted
yeah and so now like as soon as you know
Andy's the best example cuz he's the guy
that's really like come the furthest
against me other people are just
straight better than me like Dean but
you know for for Andy and I will say
this I saw it with Dean too like when I
started occasionally catching Dean Dean
started to be more open and more you
know trained more loose and that was a
long time ago but yeah you know once
once like like one day you're gonna tap
me out and then you're gonna say oh wow
Jacques game is like pretty wide open
cuz I'll I'll be doing more stuff taking
more risks and stuff like that cuz right
now you haven't and so I don't want to
give up that little something you know
so it's that's my ego you know and it
sucks but that's just the reality of it
the thing that's cool about it is
makes you like makes you go like a
little harder right makes me go hard
yeah yeah yeah there's let's face it
there's some days you come in and you're
like you got the look on your face
today's the day somebody's the Big Dave
oh I guess every day fuck yeah nobody
but but there's some days where you
believe that yeah you have something
Greg Jane showed you something shows you
something you're like today is the big
day
at one move it's gonna change everything
so true like with like if you there's
actually a lot of a lot of things that
you taught me specifically to do against
him yeah yeah varying levels of success
with those ones but yeah still not
ultimately successful nonetheless though
yes
but here's the thing there's and I think
that's a common thing though where you
know like guys coming up or whatever and
then they have that one or two guys in
the gym where it's like I just never can
top that guy out like they're just and
if I ever do it's a and it has a lot to
do with their relationship to just like
some styles yeah yes style yeah
I do some I do better against some
people than I do gets other people who
do better against other people that I do
better against them yeah definitely some
style mixes that that play in to the
whole situation yeah but like the r is
far as relationships go kind of like how
you mentioned how it's like you know
sense for lack of better way of putting
it my your record against me is perfect
you're you're like a million and oh or
whatever then the winds are the the
losses are at zero so either you're
undefeated are you not undefeated so the
fact that you're a quote-unquote
undefeated that's something that's an
additional thing you don't have
that's our relation jujitsu relationship
part of it part of the relationship
whatever so you have that so there is
motivation in you whether it be immature
mature ego but whatever your followers
it's there is motivation in you to
protect that element immature its ego
and it's there oh yeah and it's not like
you'll be like I shouldn't do that let
me uh take more risks and let ecotype me
out like I don't see that happening sure
could whatever but I don't see that
happening and that's to me that is part
of the whole game yeah that's right and
that's what I mean when when it can
depend on to people's relationship and
not
whether their friends are not friends
I'm just saying there dude it's a
relationship where it's like if this
guy's never tapped me out ever never
like there's something additional in
that relationship think of how many
times we've rolled that's a lot of rolls
so psychologically now not only are you
wanting to keep the perfect record going
mean extra stingy but like when you end
up tapping in one day or when first time
you tap me so I was ahead of you for a
long time and then you catch me one day
and then your mind is opened up yes I
did it once now it's possible yeah I
think I think the roles are different
like after that moment you're like yeah
now that your son realizes it's possible
and so now they're more aggressive just
more confident yeah yeah I look at it to
from the from the your point of view
like when EKKO caught you for the first
time then it's like okay that I don't
know that that that yeah you don't have
the protector thing is there right so
it's like okay cool you know and for
from your perspectives like okay I'm
gonna try this because I wouldn't really
try it cuz it's a little more risk and
next thing you know you have a better
you're gonna have better roles because
there's they're more fluid and actually
now that I think back the one of the
reasons that Dean got so good is like
once I I mean I probably tapped him out
like when when he was a purple belt like
like caught him in something whatever
but like after that he was just so wide
open he would try the craziest things
and he wouldn't care if I caught him it
wasn't no it wasn't a big deal
and so I think that's the ultimate way
to progress is that's kind of the way I
wrong with Andy now to like we're just
going for stuff and again I'll take huge
risk kind of if I get tapped I don't
it's not like I go cool you tap you know
I got that sucked or whatever you know
but if it's not that big of a deal you
know and you you you get more out of the
training like you like an hour later
it's not that big a deal I Drive home
you're thinking about
am i oh man trust me no you're right
like you have some tough drive homes if
you if you yeah if you data to your
point echo sometimes you get tapped out
by someone you're like man like that
shouldn't happen what'd I do wrong what
am I even doing raining whatever maybe I
should just work on my pistol pistol
rifle shooting Qualls right let's keep
that stuff up speed is its ain't in
front the funny if you want to know the
funniest thing about this whole
conversation is I'm the guy that tells
people like oh what should I do but did
you - hey put your ego check you know
enjoy and I'm clearly I'm saying freely
that it's hard to put that ego in check
is it would you would you say there's
any value to ego and jujitsu like in in
the negative way like like obviously
obviously we want to keep our EU in
check for all these important reasons
but the competitive people the people
that are always trying to win are
getting better faster and if you have
any like you're stingy about no egos
definitely good you need to have you
need to have some ego for sure because
if I didn't have any ego then I first of
all I wouldn't even be here I wouldn't
even be here cuz he goes what makes you
want to come back and learn how to win
you know man the first time that I ever
got tapped out from jujitsu I was like
okay I need to learn whatever that is
cuz this is the most horrible thing ever
to have somebody able to dominate you
like that that's never gonna happen I
hate that that was pure ego if I didn't
have an ego I would have thought to
myself well I guess that guy's stronger
or whatever you know like I don't care
no you don't try to get rid of your ego
you just keep it in check you got to
keep the ego in check if you don't have
your ego in check you know there's
another thing like we were talking about
today like if you caught me you'd be
like let's shake hands and roll again
you wouldn't like be like yeah finally
yeah and I've seen people do that on the
map I've seen people go yeah you know
like all celebratory cuz they tapped out
their friend yeah you know what I mean
and you got it that's not cool like
that's that's just offensive yeah so man
just relax like you know you know I say
it all the time and I'll say this too
and I it's like hey do Jitsu works if
you do a jujitsu move to me and I don't
defend it it's gonna work I'm gonna tap
out that's what happens what you did -
yeah you know the ego here's where the
ego get you hurt is if I go well you
know I'm not gonna tap - echoes Chimaera
so I'm just gonna get my shoulder ripped
apart right no like jujitsu works you
make a mistake your teammate capitalizes
on it you're gonna get tapped out that's
the way it is deal with it and you know
that's the way life is - that's the way
life works like you're not gonna bat a
thousand man it's not gonna happen
unless you don't get in there like I
could stop rolling to you right now echo
echo you will never catch me cold tears
I'm never gonna roll with you again yeah
that would be the weakest approach ever
yeah you know and still Eagle by the way
like how you're saying yeah keep it in
check it's more like if you can control
it and almost like harness it really in
a way where you have these guys have big
egos and they get good fast cuz they're
like real competitive they don't like to
lose or whatever but it's like that ego
is driving them to do that they're going
like forward in the right direction as
far as you know learned jujitsu and
competing a lot of time but at the same
time if you let the kind of the ego
control you it can do some weirdo things
to you too like literally you can be
going to jiu-jitsu and your ego can just
tell you don't go to Jesus anymore it's
just like that example right because I
don't want to get tapped up you'd want
to get tough down yeah that's I hate
that oh yeah I hate that I will beat
myself - I will beat that attitude into
submission I will beat myself into
submission of like oh you don't you
think you can avoid training today
you know oh you when I hear that little
voice in the back well you know you got
jet lag if you go you might get caught I
go oh really you need to shut up and
here's the thing what I think the way
I'd come combat that attitude is I if
you don't go you're taking a step back
that's that scares me more than anything
like oh if I don't train right now that
means I'm going backwards so learning
wise and yeah learning technique timing
skill so if I say oh I look at it every
if I don't train
I'm if look if I go and train and I get
beat cool I'm at least like me
making progress on the mountain yeah you
don't even go to the mountain right no
it's not just that you don't show up at
the mountain you're going backwards the
the goal posts are moving that's the
important thing like the bus is moving
yeah
your if you're not if you don't even get
on you might get on the bus and get
bullied a little bit least you're on the
bus but if you don't get now if you
don't get on the bus today because you
didn't want to get bullied that's okay
so you made that decision you feel you
might feel a little better about it
today she didn't get bullied then you
then what what happened is the next time
you show up all the bullies are a little
bit stronger then you are especially if
you don't go on the bus for a week two
weeks three weeks I look at every day
that I don't get on the bus I know
what's happening do and I don't like it
mm-hmm
so get on the bus but that's how the
right where that be you end up there and
we know you know some of our good
friends ended up there where it's like
oh he was off the bus and now it's like
men you got to get back on that hostile
bus and it's even more hostile yeah
that's getting hostile all the time so
you think I'm come getting on the bus
tomorrow more hostile than today and
I've even gone today I'm not getting out
to Mars to be more hostile then guess
what the bus is even a mile further now
more hops and now are you gonna go the
next bullies on the bus now have knives
stab you in it oh yeah big time so at
the end of the day you're never getting
on that bus it's just too far it's two
down the street and if you do you're
gonna have to get on there you have to
scrap the back to position here I've got
the PVC pipe out yeah I start going back
up the hill that's the way it works it
becomes so obvious that Eagle is the
only thing keeping you from there you
could only make other excuses for so
long and then after all those go away
like six months down the road okay why
aren't you looking there was making this
big deal out of it even though they're
like we're totally not good there's like
our friend who will remain nameless even
though we talk about him all the time on
here he like he'll be like oh yeah he'll
say that like oh yeah people you know
know they won't respect my jujitsu so he
didn't say those words but it's kind of
like that's kind of what it is but no
one cares no one cares about that stuff
or whatever oh you lost a step cuz
you've been out for years
oh we don't know not only doesn't
knowing here we kind
like that's kind of to be expected and
that happens to all of us kind of thing
we'll make a bigger deal in a positive
way that he's there more so than any
shortcomings that you may have developed
you know so it's like man it's all
upside for you coming aside from that
they might care at the moment like oh
that's interesting this person is a
purplevelvet a suck now yeah get over by
the time they get home they have their
own lives to think about oh yeah they're
not thinking about it no because it's
it's not even close to a good enough
reason for you not to show up and yeah
it's not even close I mean it's true
generally to just in in life like you
whenever you have that feeling you
should train yourself like that you're
talking yeah and get that feeling that
uncomfortable feeling that should be
like a trigger to do that the biggest
trigger for me to do is the feeling of I
don't want to do it that to me says oh I
have that same thing with working out
you know like I always look at working
out like if you missed a workout you
don't get to make up the workout I think
it's gone it's gone you never give her
if you miss a training session of
jiu-jitsu it's gone that bus went
further those people those kids on that
bus got stronger and you didn't I show
that that conversation with Jade
actually your brother where I I invited
him to speak at a class I was taking
anyways and then he's like yeah like
right away he said yeah and then he told
me later I think we had a conversation
later and maybe was right then anyways
he was saying like a he felt
uncomfortable for about a split second
he said but he's already sort of had
that self talk in the past where it that
moment he feels uncomfortable you know
that he needs to do that
mm-hmm you don't want to you don't want
to say no or make excuses because it's
just gonna eat at you yeah well hey
we've been kicking it for like a little
over an hour I think the message of the
day is get on the bus
keep training Greg do you got any social
media yeah you need to make it like a
Greg train at or whatever yeah I need to
embrace it where you have at Gregory
McIntyre is that for it that's Instagram
yeah okay say it again spell it Gregory
McIntyre
Gregory McIntyre's MC int y re that's my
Instagram and I think it's the same yet
the same for but Twitter I just kind of
like yeah some people are leaving
Twitter the bus is leaving them if you
want to talk to echo he's at echo
Charles I'm at chocoholic if you want to
need you Jitsu stuff or supplement stuff
go to origin main calm and if you want
to check out a different podcast that we
have it's called Jocko podcast and go to
Jocko podcast calm you can get stuff
from chocolate store if you want us to
keep doing this that's all we got
go get on the bus everyone we'll talk to
you later
how